bonjour La voix est Libre en direct tous
les samedis sur France 3 avec
aujourd'hui 4 voix pour parler de ces
élections départementales qui viennent
de se terminer marqué en Bourgogne par
la bascule à droite de la Saône-et-Loire
et le nouveau président UMP du conseil
départemental est avec nous bonjour
André carry bonjour Merci d'avoir trouvé
un peu de temps dans ces premiers jours
forcément bousculés sur ce plateau
Delphine Fleury conseillère socialiste
de la Nièvre bonjour réélu sur le canton
de Nevers 2 Marie-Laure capitale réélu
conseillère départemental DVD du canton
de Saint-Florentin dans l'Yonne bonjour
et un nouveau amis de la Sony conseiller
départemental socialiste du canton de
Dijon 3 bonjour à vous bonjour et chez
vous pendant cette émission vous pouvez
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux et
Internet comme d'habitude on a fait
beaucoup de politiques depuis deux mois
on va en faire encore un peu mais on va
prendre le temps de s'arrêter aussi nos
caméras ont été sur certains et
certaines d'entre vous pendant à des
moments cruciaux de ces élections on
vous a vu mais il faut que vous nous
racontiez ces moments celui où on
comprend qu'on a gagné ou celui dans
lequel on craint de ne pas avoir gagné
Andrea carry on se souvient vous étiez
crayon en main en train de faire les
comptes quel souvenir vous regardez de
cette soirée du deuxième tour tout
d'abord une soirée évidemment un petit
peu tendu puisque on a on a un stress
obligatoire puisque rien n'est acquis on
savait que la Saône-et-Loire serait une
élection quand même particulièrement
difficile il y a eu un travail de fond
assez long donc c'est vrai que on avait
une vraie problématique c'était huit
triangulaires donc effectivement la
soirée du deuxième tour était plutôt
stressante vous avez toujours été
confiant oui un moment où vous avez été
non non d'abord c'est ma nature j'ai
plutôt plutôt une nature optimiste donc
effectivement j'ai toujours été confiant
mais toujours extrêmement prudent parce
que au final le long on le sait bien
c'est les électeurs qui décident
Fleury il y avait une équipe de
reportage avec vous le soir des
résultats beaucoup d'émotions quand vous
apprenez le résultat
particulière il y avait une raison
particulière c'était juste l'élection où
cette é là c'était cette élection là
particulièrement parce que j'ai été là
sortante là avant c'était mon premier
mandat donc bon je vais pas dire que
c'était plus facile mais il y avait un
poids en moins on a une responsabilité
supplémentaire quand on est sortant
j'étais sur le canton qui était
renouvelé mais qui est quand on
historique de la gauche parce que
c'était le canton de kerbergovoy de
Marcel charmant donc bon voilà il y
avait un vrai challenge et puis le
contexte qui était quand même très rude
et difficile donc jusqu'au bout
effectivement beaucoup de de on est
tendu quoi on se dit on va attendre
vraiment que les derniers résultats
tombent du dernier bureau de vote pour
être bien sûr parce que moi j'avais
l'équipe autour de moi qui me disait bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
les gens chez eux ils se disent non mais
les candidats ils ont ils ont des
sondages ils ont des gens qui leur donne
des indications ils ont plein de choses
pour savoir c'est quoi la réalité des
soirées comme ça il y a des gens qui
vous appellent qui vous dites dans ce
bureau dans ce bureau dans ce bureau
voilà c'est bon c'est pas bon on quand
même qui est des gens dans les bureaux
de vote pour nous donner les résultats
au moment où il tombe alors à Nevers on
a parce que le canton de verdeux il y a
une partie Nevers et puis il y a
d'autres communes qui sont plus rurales
on va dire donc dans les communes
rurales c'est avec les bulletins de vote
traditionnel mais à Nevers c'est les
machines à voter donc à Nevers les
bureaux de vote ferme à 18h à 18h15 on a
les résultats enfin ça va très vite quoi
donc dès 18h15 ouais on avait les
résultats de Nevers et Nevers c'était le
la partie la plus importante pour en
termes de nombre de voix mais c'est
aussi puisque c'est des quartiers très
populaires donc là où ça s'abstient
quand même le plus donc c'était
important d'avoir tous les autres
résultats il faut attendre entre 18h15
et puis
19h15 c'est long vous vous avez de
l'expérience vous avez déjà été élu
c'est toujours la même chose il y a
toujours ce stress il y a toujours ce
stress surtout enfin pour les élections
ces dernières élections au premier tour
puisque je me suis retrouvé en
compétition avec une autre liste de
droite on va en parler c'est bien sûr le
contexte très fort de et puis également
donc le Front National qui était sur une
grande partie des cantons au deuxième
tour premier tour était très fort aussi
très fort moi le premier tour était
beaucoup plus stressant que que les
résultats du deuxième tour oui oui il y
a toujours quand même avant d'être sûr
au deuxième tour
cette angoisse ce truc qui fait qu'on se
dit comme ça c'est quelque chose on
attend les derniers résultats comme
disait madame on n'a pas toutes les
toutes les communes et la dernière
commune qui arrive on se dit ouf ça y
est enfin enfin enfin on a on a gagné
entre guillemets
vous il y a une problématique encore
plus particulière parce que vous étiez
lu dans un canton qui compte le quartier
dont vous êtes originaire exactement
je suppose qu'on est au-delà de
l'émotion habituelle des élus c'est une
aventure extraordinaire du commun avec
évidemment
émaillé d'embûches et des preuves et
c'était pour moi un petit peu mon
baptême de feu avec pour la première
fois dans mon histoire dans mon parcours
de vie sa photo affichée sur les
panneaux et j'avais aussi cheville au
corps la volonté de défendre des valeurs
et des principes je suis un enfant
je suis néogrésil j'habite au Grésilles
quartier populaire par excellence
qui a été tant stigmatisé mais qui a
fait la démonstration par la preuve on
se mobilisant énormément le jour de
l'élection qui avait aussi une constance
politique et c'est vrai que le soir du
deuxième tour j'étais submergé par
l'émotion et aussi par le sentiment du
devoir accompli mais aussi le poids des
responsabilités parce que aujourd'hui
c'est très bien d'avoir été élu mais
derrière et la résidence est encore plus
forte quand les gens qui ont voté pour
vous c'est les gens qui sont liés à
votre histoire personnelle on a devant
moral de ne pas les décevoir parce que
vous savez dans ces quartiers là même si
c'est un quartier en pleine métamorphose
en pleine transformation il y a quand
même de la souffrance il y a des
attentes énormes donc on est un petit
peu les premiers à être exposés en
première ligne et c'est vrai que on a le
devoir aussi de ne pas décevoir et en
tout cas on se donnera les moyens de
répondre à leurs préoccupations on a
déjà un petit peu d'expérience puisque
je suis aussi accessoirement adjoint au
maire de Dijon des dégâts à jeunesse
depuis maintenant 6 ans mais avec avec
vraiment le bâton de pèlerin d'aller
justement essayer justement de trouver
des solutions pour chaque une situation
individuelles c'est oui l'attacher
lourde mais on est plein d'énergie et
plein de bonnes volonté c'est peut-être
il y a mon âge mais en tout cas je suis
plein du topi et d'énergie on a beaucoup
parlé du mode de scrutin nouveau
ce qu'on a entendu aussi beaucoup
c'était finalement les candidats ont été
surpris par les conséquences de ce mode
de scrutin on est élu par plus de gens
qu'avant parfois l'élection conseil
général c'est un peu une élection de
notable on connaissait à peu près tous
les gens qui allaient voter pour vous
les distances n'étaient pas très longues
beaucoup de candidats nous ont dit deux
choses après l'élection qu'ils étaient
absolument épuisés par rapport à
d'habitude et que c'était finalement
plutôt une petite élection législative
une élection cantonale Marie-Laure
capitain vous diriez ça aussi oui
c'était une élection
épuisante puisque au niveau des
périmètres donc le nouveau redécoupage
des cantons on s'est retrouvés donc avec
des nombre commune puisque je suis
passée de 14 communes à 22 communes qui
représente 19000 habitants donc moi
j'avais l'habitude de faire une campagne
je fais du porte-à-porte et on a donc
visité toutes les communes plus les
réunions du soir donc c'est vrai qu'au
bout de la 10e 11e commune ont commencé
à être vraiment épuisé mais voilà
c'était c'était la pratique que j'avais
mise en place depuis 98 et j'ai continué
le changement des cantons est-ce qu'il a
généré aussi une autre façon de faire de
la politique c'est à dire que on peut
pas aller directement à tous les
électeurs il faut aussi générer du
message essayer de faire passer un
certain nombre de signaux est-ce que ça
implique de faire de la politique
autrement vous avez été conseillère
générale auparavant vous oui bah là
c'est effectivement avec le redécoupage
des cantons moi j'ai eu des communes
plus rurales qui sont venus s'ajouter
plutôt
urbaine j'avais une une commune à coller
à Nevers c'est tout et là il y a
Manicourt
serre Moise donc plus plus rural
effectivement donc là c'est une autre
manière parce que sur Nevers et même
Saint-Éloi on avait l'habitude de faire
du portable bon les rayons publiques
bien sûr là il a fallu aussi sur
Manicourt moi j'étais une parfaite
inconnue parce que il était dans un
autre canton donc il fallait se faire
connaître oui c'est une manière
différente ouais ça c'est sûr avec une
problématique qui est que on fait des
réunions publiques mais les gens ne
viennent très peu enfin
Andréa carry
législative ça je suis assez d'accord
non mais la vraie problématique aussi il
a fallu faire beaucoup de pédagogie
vis-à-vis des électeurs puisque pour eux
tout était nouveau d'abord on leur a
expliqué pendant des mois et des mois
que que les départements les
disparaissent ça servait à rien que ça
coûtait cher et ensuite effectivement
c'était les grands secteurs donc
effectivement avec un nouveau chef-lieu
de canton donc c'est vrai qu'il a fallu
passer beaucoup de temps en fait c'était
vraiment d'ailleurs moi je commençais
mes réunions publiques par ça
j'expliquais ce qu'il en était pourquoi
finalement fallait voter et puis et puis
pourquoi on était quatre sur une liste
aussi donc il y a eu une partie
pédagogique assez intéressante à faire
parce que pour le coup c'était
intéressant mais en même temps les
personnes ont vraiment et je pense c'est
aussi c'est en partie une explication
c'est pas la seule mais c'est une des
explications le nom de l'abstention
du mode de scrutin il l'a dit André
Karim en parlant des équipes A4 c'était
les binômes mais binômes plus les
remplaçants ça faisait 4 personnes quand
on a annoncé ce mode de scrutin moi je
me souviens de beaucoup d'élus sortants
qui mograit tous en disant qu'est-ce que
ça va être que ce cirque et le paradoxe
c'est que depuis quelques jours beaucoup
nous racontent que ça a été une aventure
qu'ils ont beaucoup aimé finalement
un petit mot sur le redécoupage des
cantons qui devenait une étape
inévitable dans la mesure où on instaure
un nouvel équilibre en fonction du
nombre d'habitants et non pas en
fonction des territoires
c'est un quotient électoral bien sûr
effectivement équilibré mais cette loi
de février 2013 elle a aussi instauré un
binôme homme c'est quand même une
avancée sociétale aujourd'hui on va
parler de la parité bien sûr donc voilà
un moment donné c'est quand même une
avancée extraordinaire et je pense que
ce qu'on retiendra dans les livres
d'histoire dans quelques années dans
quelques décennies bah c'est le fait
qu'on est redécoupé les cantons et aussi
instaurer beaucoup plus de parité au
sein des les assemblées alors
ce fait de faire campagne à deux comme
ça
alors les gens le plus grand public a vu
à deux est-ce que tout le monde nous dit
c'est qu'en réalité c'était que vous
l'avez vécu comment votre binôme elle
est quelque part dans l'ombre là-bas sur
le plateau et elle me disait avant cette
émission que ça avait été une aventure
aussi qu'elle avait beaucoup aimé et
vous êtes dans ce cas-là mais c'est vrai
qu'avec Sandrine Lilly et
Christian De Dion et Stéphanie mode bon
c'est une équipe resserrée et on a pu
justement faire campagne dans une
ambiance conviviale c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné on doit cohabiter puisqu'on
a quand même des tempéraments des
caractères et ça c'est fait
naturellement et c'est aussi peut-être
ça l'ingrédient de la réussite c'est
qu'à partir du moment où il n'y a pas de
conflit de personnalité ça permet aussi
de porter très haut le message politique
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu de la part
des électeurs une surprise de taille
elle a fait preuve de pédagogie ne
serait-ce que par rapport aux
compétences du Conseil départemental
c'est la grosse inconnue il a fallu leur
expliquer que
le Conseil départemental
parce que les gens votent pour les
conseils généraux depuis des décennies
sans savoir ce qu'ils font hein
pédagogie que qu'on sait pas qu'ils vont
faire oui je pense que c'est quand même
c'est en dit long sur la stratégie
actuelle puisque c'est quand même la
première fois dans l'histoire
les électeurs se prononcent sur une
collectivité sans connaître
l'aboutissement finalement des
compétences avec on le sait on a pu voir
parce que c'est des faits c'est même pas
une théorie politique des allers-retours
incroyables sur les compétences
éventuellement à venir ou pas pour au
final revenir voilà la loi la loi neutre
qui est actuellement discussion au
Parlement a priori il devrait pas y
avoir de modifications significative qui
relève de l'action vous le dites
vous-même a priori donc c'est c'est
quand même incroyable alors voilà voilà
pour l'instant ce qui est pas tranché
c'est la clause de compétence générale
c'est ce qui permettait aux
collectivités de faire ce qu'elle
voulait en gros et la question est de
savoir est-ce qu'on reviendra aux comp
obligatoire on a parlé des binômes et
donc ça nous amène forcément sur un
point absolument central de cette
élection c'est la parité qui est de fait
maintenant dans les dans les conseils
départementaux
il y avait que 14% de femmes dans toute
la France avant j'ai envie de vous dire
il était temps Marie-Laure pitain quand
même c'est ça parité c'est une avancée
notoire
oui puisque enfin c'est une avancée
notoire d'avoir des femmes donc
maintenant au sein des assemblées
départementales même si il a fallu qu'il
y ait une voix pour pour que les femmes
puissent puissent se présenter au niveau
du conseil départemental donc de l'Yonne
nous étions trois femmes en 1998 nous
sommes passés à 5 en 2011 et aujourd'hui
nous sommes 21 femmes assiégées au
conseil départemental et je trouve que
c'est une belle avancée et j'attends
avec impatience les futurs les futurs
réunions où je pense que les femmes vont
devoir s'imposer et apporter une autre
une autre réflexion sur sur les dossiers
qui vont être présentés il va falloir
que vous fassiez avec maintenant
c'est pas non plus un supplice c'est
volontairement provocateur
je pense que globalement tout le monde
est unanime est évident ce qui était
dommage d'ailleurs c'est d'en passer par
la loi mais c'est ainsi bon et pourtant
il n'y a que des présidents hommes dans
notre région
il va falloir du temps ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir du temps
ce que vous vous êtes les héritiers et
les présidents d'aujourd'hui sont les
héritiers du système précédent bien sûr
maintenant pour le coup elles vont se
faire naturellement j'espère que la loi
n'aura pas à trancher aussi sur les
présidents mais à partir du moment où
vous avez une parité au niveau des
exécutifs naturellement vous allez très
vite retrouver aussi une présidence
féminine voilà naturellement
c'était une conquête quand même il
fallait en passer par par s'imposer il y
a eu un effet
notoire effectivement là pour cette
élection et c'est tant mieux y compris
le fait qu'on ait des des femmes plus
jeunes et jeunes en politique aussi qui
se du coup se sont retrouvés avec à
faire ce mandat et là ça apporte oui
enfin moi je pense que ça apportera en
tout cas une manière de faire de voir
les choses un point de vue différent qui
peut être que bénéfique sur la manière
de conduire nos politiques
peut-être plus moins politisés plus
terre à terre plus proche de la réalité
avec
souvent qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir de
concret au bout comment ça va se
traduire concrètement sur le terrain des
gens parce que là dans cette campagne on
a bien vu aussi l'attente de la
population par rapport à la plus de
proximité à faire en sorte que ce soit
plus visible plus d'explications aussi
la campagne l'a permis mais c'est une
attente aussi des gens qui très forte
par rapport à ça et notamment sur les
départementales parce qu'on a quand même
vous l'avez dit des gens qui qui ne
voient pas qui ne perçoivent pas même si
le Conseil départemental maintenant agit
au quotidien dans la vie des gens voilà
avec les collèges la petite enfance
enfin bon on va pas énumérer tout ce
qu'on a dit pendant la campagne mais les
personnes âgées
il y a eu un petit un petit regard
particulier quand vous avez élu le
président du conseil départemental de la
Nièvre jeudi quand vous avez vu 50% de
femmes dans cette émission
oui oui c'était c'était
quelque chose de enfin moi je trouve que
c'est bien quoi c'est formidable c'est
enthousiasmant j'ai des jeunes collègues
des voilà enfin on a une jeune femme
Anne vérin qui est lui sur le canton de
Corbigny voilà son premier gros mandat
les mamans de 3 enfants en bas âge enfin
moi je trouve ça génial quoi voilà on
est parce qu'on a eu du mal il faut le
dire dans les listes de pour les
quadrino mais les binômes à trouver les
femmes qui voulaient accepter de
s'engager ça a pas été évident partout
je sais pas si en tout cas sur la Nièvre
il y a parfois eu des cantons ou il
fallait quand même il fallait en passer
par là il fallait en passer par le phase
obligatoire à mi de la semaine mais
sinon il y aurait pas eu après c'est
vrai que malheureusement pour faire
évoluer les mentalités il faut plusieurs
décennies donc il a fallu adopter un
texte de loi mais c'est vrai que moi ce
que j'ai constaté au sein des assemblées
départementales c'est la conjonction de
deux phénomènes c'est évidemment
l'instauration de la parité homme et
aussi peut-être un renouvellement des
générations et donc ça apporte un peu
plus un vent nouveau un peu plus de
fraîcheur peut-être une autre vision de
la politique un peu moins dogmatique
beaucoup plus pragmatique et c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui c'est ça permet
peut-être de se dire que notre
démocratie notre République est
peut-être est en meilleure santé et que
vous savez mieux que moi que en règle
générale pour identifier le portrait
type d'un élu vous savez c'est 60 ans
plutôt notable un homme d'appareil
jusque là pendant que je vous tiens à
mes délestine j'ai envie de vous parler
d'autre chose aussi on a beaucoup parlé
de la parité il y a un élément dont on
parle pas dans ces élections
départementales alors on peut appeler ça
de différentes manières mais ça peut
être l'expression de la diversité vous
êtes vous le disiez issu d'un quartier
très spécifique vous avez grandi dans ce
quartier la parité elle est faite la
diversité très clairement si on fait les
photos de nos quatre conseils
départementaux bourguignon elle n'existe
pas elle est pas le reflet des
départements qui ont voté
il faudrait quoi il faudrait une loi ça
semble difficilement possible il
faudrait du temps on sait par exemple
que dans les conseils régionaux cette
diversité s'est exprimée un petit peu
plus à certains moments dans les
conseils municipaux aussi non mais force
de constater que je suis l'arbre qui
cache la forêt et que j'ai identifié
plusieurs freins commencer par les
appareils politiques qui ont tendance à
ne pas faire confiance à des
candidatures qui reflètent la diversité
pour ce que il y a des pseudos
accusations d'incompétence ou de rejets
potentiel de l'électorat ce qui est
complètement faux j'en suis la preuve
aujourd'hui et c'est faire en sorte
aussi que les mentalités évoluent vu le
climat d'aujourd'hui
certains intellectuels au sein des
partis politiques avec leurs petites
calculatrice avec leurs différents
scénaris leurs différentes suppositions
s'imaginent que le fait d'être issu de
l'immigration ou issus de la diversité
est un handicap je suis persuadé du
contraire
entendu je l'ai forcément entendu mais
quel que soit les partis politiques mais
je pense que l'opinion publique est
prête à accepter des élus qui reflètent
la diversité de notre pays c'est pas un
handicap c'est un atout c'est une chance
et ça il faut que certaines personnes se
mettent dans la tête j'ai envie de le
demander mon président du conseil
départemental Andrea Karim ils étaient
tranquillement mais
c'est une question que vous vous êtes
posé quand vous avez fait les binômes et
les kadrinos vous regrettez vous l'avez
pas fait parce que il y a pas il y a
très peu dans votre majorité il y en a
même quasiment pas je crois d'expression
des minorités du pays
tout d'abord je voudrais revenir moi
dans la cadre de la préparation de des
élections
vous parliez tout à l'heure parce que
les assemblées départementales c'était
très féminisé donc il y aurait moins de
dogmatisme grâce je suis pas du tout
d'accord
tout dépend comment on a constitué légis
moi j'ai fait un gros travail de fond ou
effectivement il y a
beaucoup de représentants de la société
civile
parce que le dogmatisme peut aussi bien
féminin masculin donc quand on veut
apporter effectivement un regard nouveau
sur une assemblée départementale en tout
cas celle que je préside je voulais
effectivement au départ dans le choix
des listes vraiment ouvrir
à des gens qui ne sont pas du tout dans
le système politique et c'est pour ça
que je me retrouve
enfin entouré d'une équipe
effectivement très rajeuni ça c'est
clair ça ça a été une spécificité de de
cette élection très rajeuni certes très
féminisée bien sûr mais aussi très
variés dans les compétences
professionnelles des uns et des autres
donc effectivement sur la population et
sur la photo de la population par
rapport au Conseil départementaux qui
ont va le rappeler s'occupe du social
s'occupe de la solidarité donc d'un
certain nombre de populations qui sont
très concernés moi j'ai vraiment été
ouvert dans dans la préparation de ces
élections à ce que tout le monde
effectivement puisse faire entendre sa
voix donc après il faut qu'il y ait
aussi des solution personnelle peut-être
que dans la formation des équipes vous
savez quand on parle aussi de féminiser
mais il fallait aussi que et vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs c'était difficile de
trouver quelquefois des candidates
féminines mais c'est vrai dans tous les
domaines y compris dans la
représentation il faut aussi que des
personnes qui fassent entendre leur voix
qui entre guillemets qui s'imposent et
puis qui porte aussi un message
politique aussi mais finalement parce
que c'est des partis politiques le
filtre qui amène à la candidature et à
l'élection alors bien sûr c'est un des
filtres bien sûr mais si vous regardez
moi la composition en tout cas le
département que je connais le mieux
évidemment vous verrez qu'il y a pas eu
que ces filtres là il y a eu justement
une vraie ouverture sur d'autres talents
donc je pense que
l'ouverture peut se faire aussi mais il
faut aussi que les gens voilà
s'expriment et donne cette envie de mais
après il y a des principes de réalité
dans l'imaginaire collectif des
appareils politiques le fait d'avoir des
candidatures atypiques
peut être considéré comme un handicap et
moi je suis persuadé du contraire je
pense que l'opinion publique est prête
mais que les états majors des différents
partis politiques ne le sont pas c'est
une réalité et aussi un deuxième message
à faire passer auprès des populations
issues de l'immigration mais qui sont
Français à part entière c'est d'investir
les partis politiques prouver votre
existence votre envie de bien faire en
justement en adhérant dans les parties
politiques peu importe le parti mais
justement l'idée c'est que ces parties
sont ouverts au plus grand nombre et
c'est pour ça qu'on constate un taux
d'abstention record dans les quartiers
d'habitat social
justement ça vous nous amener sur
finalement la dimension politique de
cette de cette élection marqué on l'a
dit par participation faible même si on
s'est félicité d'un notion en plus enfin
globalement c'était une participation
faible
au niveau national j'entends pas quand
on part canton et puis bien sûr la
présence du Front national qui a été
extrêmement importante
moi j'ai envie de vous demander alors on
va commencer et puis on continuera après
les infos de midi parce qu'on aura
encore du temps
votre vision votre analyse de la
signification politique de cette
élection pour vous qu'on dit les
électeurs est-ce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
voulaient plus de droite qu'ils ont dit
qu'il voulait plus de gauche est-ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'il voulait essayer
autre chose avec le Front National et ce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils voulaient plus
vous voir en allant pas voter Delphine
Fleury ce serait quoi vous votre analyse
moi je pense que
il est malade
attention aussi fort même si il était
plus faible finalement que ce qu'on
avait dit mais quand même quoi et puis
quand on voit les scores du Front
national avec des candidats qui sont
parfaits inconnus qui souvent il
suffisait d'avoir le portrait de Marine
Le Pen pour voilà faire campagne pas de
proposition enfin c'était nous dans la
Nièvre on était effaré quoi
néanmoins c'est une constante mais il y
a 126 908 personnes on a compté qui ont
voté pour le Front national en Bourgogne
ça veut donc dire qu'en faisant ça ils
ont voulu envoyer un message et vous
allez nous dire vous tous que vous
pensez qui était ce message pour vous
espérons par rapport à au fait que
leur quotidien ne change pas malgré les
changements politiques il peut y avoir
et notamment au niveau national depuis
longtemps donc ils sont toujours dans
des souffrances voilà grandes il ne voit
pas leur vie évoluer celle de leur de
leurs enfants aux petits-enfants parce
que on dit que les personnes âgées
votent plus mais nous on a rencontré les
personnes âgées qui nous disaient
qu'elle n'allait pas aller voter souvent
pour la première fois de leur vie parce
qu'autour d'elle elle-même ou autour
d'elle ça ne changeait rien voilà moi je
voulais revenir donc sur mon canton
parce que effectivement le Front
national a été
a été un grand risque puisque je me suis
deuxième tour il était au deuxième tour
et je pense que notre canton a pris un
prix un grand risque puisque nous avions
deux listes de droite ou normalement
nous étions tous tous soudés
UMP et udi et
le fait d'avoir refusé donc d'avoir un
candidat UMP sur ma liste a provoqué une
scission et on s'est donc retrouvé avec
ces deux listes udi UMP mais remplaçant
donc ont quitté le navire et se sont
retrouvés
titulaire sur l'autre liste alors
effectivement là on prenait un grand
risque puisque nous avions deux listes
de droite plus
dump et bien sûr les candidats PS donc
je pense que est-ce que ça par exemple
ce genre de comportement ça a aussi pu
accentuer le déplacement des gens vers
le Front national disant vos appareils
on en a marre vos histoires on en a
marre des parties qui imposent leurs
candidats il faut prendre des personnes
qui vivent sur le terrain des candidats
de proximité et en plus bon voilà
j'avais je suis là depuis 98 on ne
connaissait sur le terrain vient que
avec le redécoupage
et là il y avait encore un risque
puisqu'on on nous connaissait pas que ce
soit pour mon pour mon binôme André
Girard ou moi un versement sur son
secteur et on va dire que par rapport au
Front national on a vu dans cette
campagne aussi une différence d'attitude
entre l'UDI et l'UMP sur l'Yonne ou les
délits étaient clairement dans une
logique de front républicain qui était
pas forcément le cas de l'UMP on peut
dire que la ligne de fracture était
comme ça dans le département de l'Yonne
on a tout à fait dans les gros yeux mais
dans le département de l'Yonne c'était
comme ça
c'était Nini j'ai pas pu avoir un
soutien franc dans pour ma candidature
enfin pour notre candidature au deuxième
tour et c'est là qu'il y a eu l'appel de
germinier par le président de rivier
pour rassembler l'ensemble des équipes
c'est à dire à la fois le psud l'UMP et
grâce à cela je pense que on a pu on a
pu gagner le deuxième tour voilà parce
que c'était vraiment très très fragile
c'était tendu il nous reste une minute
avant les infos du midi on continuera
bien sûr après mais votre vision un
drakkarys ils ont dit quoi pour vous les
électeurs est-ce que est-ce que la
droite passe en Saône-et-Loire parce
qu'ils veulent plus de droite ou est-ce
que le problème est quand même un petit
peu plus vaste un peu plus profond non
mais c'est évident le problème est plus
vaste et en moins d'une minute plus
vaste et plus profond mais je vous
remercie de me laisser quelques secondes
on y revient après on continue
globalement je vous dirai d'abord c'est
pas le score du Front national
c'est des gens de droite de gauche ou
non sans aucune sensibilité qui ont voté
effectivement la liste de Front national
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un manque
d'écoute et c'est vrai qu'ils sont
désespérés la plupart mais je pense que
cette seule explication ne suffit pas
non plus il nous reste à une trentaine
de secondes donc on va pas engager la
suite on continuera bien sûr après les
infos de midi on continuera à parler
bien sûr de la signification politique
de ces élections par leur a peut-être un
petit peu aussi de comment vont
fonctionner les les conseils de
départementaux par la suite et puis du
lien avec quelque chose qui se profile
c'est les très grandes régions qui vont
se mettre en place avec des élections
régionales en décembre et du coup on
verra quel est votre point de vue le
niveau des départements par rapport à ça
allez on se retrouve dans cinq minutes